(electronic beeping)
- The Office of
Developmental Primary Care,
and the Department of Family
and Community Medicine at UCSF.
She provides primary care to adults
with medical fragility and
complex behavioral problems.
She has been working within this field
at least for the past 10 years.
And today is gonna talk to us
about a different kind of a topic,
which is if I can find the title here...
(laughs) Working with sensory
movement disorders and autism.
Dr. Kripke.
- Thank you so much Sherry.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
I have nothing to disclose.
So the reason why I
wanted to give this talk
is because I have come to understand
that a lot of what we know for sure
about autism just isn't true.
We've developed services
for autistic people
which are based on the belief that autism
is primarily a psychological problem
characterized by deficits
in social understanding
and restricted behaviors and interests.
But I've come to believe that autism
is better accommodated when it's
understood as a neurological condition.
Increasingly, people working
in a neurological paradigm
are achieving remarkably good outcomes,
especially for those who don't speak
or those whose speech is unreliable
and for those who have
prominent symptoms of dyspraxia.
Dyspraxia is difficulty
coordinating movement.
So what I wanna talk about today
is to lead you through this thinking,
starting with is autism a thing?
And going to what we know about sensory
and movement differences in autism.
What are the implications of that?
Is autism better accommodated when
it's understood as a
neurological difference?
What are self-advocates telling
us and why should we listen?
10 years ago, we definitely
thought autism was a thing.
And everybody was looking for the gene,
we were looking for the
vaccine that was causing it.
It's a crisis, it's taking over the world.
I think we've largely moved
through that thankfully,
although echoes of it sometimes
rear their ugly heads.
But a diagnosis of
autism doesn't correlate
with any specific trait or characteristic.
People can be super smart or have
significant cognitive challenges.
They can be organized or have
very difficult executive
function problems.
They can be, I know autistic people
who are competitive surfers
and others who use wheelchairs.
They may or may not have seizures.
They may have normal or very
acute or scrambled senses.
They might be even deaf or blind.
They might be quite regulated to a fault,
or they may have very significant
anxiety and behavior problems
and mental health problems.
So basically we're
talking about a condition
that describes the full range
of human traits and behaviors.
It's not a very specific
clinical diagnosis,
if it makes sense at all.
So how did we get here to defining
this thing called autism, it
was defined by psychiatrists
who were rooted in 20th
century cultural ideas
about intelligence,
eugenics, and social hygiene.
Early work in treatments was
based on Skinner's framework.
Skinner believed that observable behavior
is the only relevant target of treatment
and that controlled experimental designs
are the only way to
evaluate its effectiveness.
In Skinner's paradigm, we
know that a treatment works
if you present a stimulus and the person
consistently responds
in the way you expect.
For Skinner, thoughts, feelings,
emotions, any other non-observable
or less measurable aspect of
cognition is just not relevant.
Skinner thought that we don't have
to ask questions about why
people behave the way they do
beyond a simplistic analysis of A-B-C,
the stimulus, the behavior,
and the consequence.
Medical causes of behavior
changes aren't assessed.
But of course, we know
that autistic people,
what autistic people think and
feel is critically important.
Their past experiences and
traumas are completely relevant.
Their health status is crucial.
Understanding the reasons why they do
what they do is core to
developing good support.
Autism is defined in the
Diagnostic and Statistical Manual
of the American Psychiatric Associations,
but even the APA itself has begun
to question the validity of
the DSM classification scheme
because it's based on a
professional consensus
about clusters of psychological
and behavioral symptoms rather
than on more objective biological data.
And the fields of psychiatry and neurology
are growing closer together every day
as our understanding of the basic science
of both fields continues to improve.
It's pretty clear that
there isn't one autism.
Nor is it a single condition with a range
of presentations that
go from mild to severe.
Autism is a catch-all diagnosis
that includes a really wide range
of ideologies, traits, characteristics,
strengths, challenges, genes,
environment influences and biology.
Autistic people have a wide range
of strengths and challenges.
People with significant support
needs also have great gifts.
Different parts of the brain
perform different functions.
We know this, for example
there is different spots
for speech, language, and reading.
They have connections between them.
But the connections can
be too weak or too strong.
For example, someone who speaks
might have difficulty reading.
Someone who signs English
may not be able to speak.
Someone who reads and who has language
may still have trouble speaking
even though they can write.
Applied behavior analysis,
the most common treatment
for autism, assumes that what you see
is a good representation of what's going
on in the brain, but it isn't.
Many autistic people have a lot more
going on inside than they can show.
The brain is also connected to the body.
The peripheral nervous system
is made up of the afferent
motor system and the
efferent sensory system.
The efferent carries
signals from the brain
to the muscles so that we can move
and do things we wanna do.
The afferent system carries
sensory information to the brain.
Sometimes those messages get scrambled.
This leads to action problems that can
look a lot like autistic behavior.
I used to teach that all
behavior is communication,
and I'm here today to tell you
to admit, to confess, I was wrong.
Not all behavior is communication.
Some of it is not purposeful at all.
It's an artifact of difficulty organizing
and regulating the sensory
and movement system
even if it appears intentional.
We all have experience with this.
For example, how many of you have ever
changed your password and then
typed in the old password?
Your fingers just automatically
do it, it's motor memory.
You don't have a cognitive
problem, we've all done that.
How many have you have
ever gotten startled
and (blows air sharply) bopped someone
before you could process
that they aren't a threat?
Your limbic system just
went boom, fight or flight,
and your cortical brain
that understood the context
and inhibited that didn't
kick in fast enough.
You're not aggressive people.
Have you ever walked into
a crowded convention hall
where there were hundreds of conversations
and you were just hit
by this wall of sound
and you couldn't distinguish
any conversation?
You don't have, I would say you
don't have a hearing problem
but I don't know whether you do or not.
But that's not a manifestation
of a hearing problem.
Maybe when you went to
that convention hall,
you saw someone you
know and then suddenly,
you could pick out just their voice
when you couldn't distinguish
it before you saw them,
before you got that sensory
information of seeing them
and cooked up the visual
with the auditory.
Have you ever tried to learn a new dance
and the instructor's next to you
and you're rockin' out and
you're doing a really good job
and then another student is next to you
and they're flubbin' up the steps
and they've got the rhythm all wrong
and you can't do it anymore, yeah.
You weren't faking your difficulty.
You weren't someone who had
mastered that motor plan
and now in this new
environment unable to do it.
That's, we're taking
in sensory information
and that affects what we can do
in terms of our motor control.
Have you ever done a, let's
say a fine motor task,
then you get into a rhythm
and you're really fast
and accurate with it and then someone
interrupts you and you mess it up?
Yeah, I've done that too.
Have you ever gotten nervous and your body
froze or you were unable to speak?
Have you ever been in a classroom
where you could hear the professor
but you weren't turned
into what he was saying
until the professor said your name
and then suddenly you
shifted your attention
and could, were tuned into
what the professor was saying.
Autistic people who have
verbal and motor apraxia
describe bodies that
don't obey their minds.
Where these types of sensory
and movement integration glitches
happen frequently throughout the day
creating challenges with
navigating their world.
Imagine how frustrating it would be
if people assumed that these
sensory and movement glitches
actually represented cognitive
or behavioral problems
or a lack of social interests.
She typed the wrong
password, therefore she must
have terrible short-term memory.
She bopped her friend so
she must have irritability
and aggression, we need a pill for that.
She doesn't approach groups,
she must be in a world of her own.
She's demonstrated she
can write her name before
and she isn't doing it now, that must mean
that she isn't cooperative or motivated.
You can see how people would
come to these conclusions,
but it's also to see the frustration
and the despair that it could cause.
I'll tell you a story from
our cart services consult team
about how powerful it can be to understand
autism as a neurological condition.
We were consulted on a
client and the information
we were given was that this was
a client who was constantly violent.
This client, they were the regional center
was exploring out of state placement
in an institution because
nothing was helping.
They had consulted multiple behaviorists,
and none of their top
level behavioral programs
or top level behavioral homes were willing
to serve this client anymore.
And so when we went out there,
we were prepared to meet
someone who was quite dangerous.
But when we got there, we saw
what they were talking about.
This person wasn't
aggressive or violent at all.
He had more like a
repetitive movement, a tic.
And it was like this.
And it was very stereotyped,
it was always the same,
always the same hand, it was unemotional.
There was no emotion behind it.
He wasn't going after
somebody, it was just boom.
It was easily inhibited by his aides
who would just touch his arm
and he would pull it back
when they just touched his arm.
It was more like a tic than an attack.
And if you stood close to
him on that side of his body
right in that line, he'd
get you and it would hurt.
But we asked, has he caused any injuries?
No, no injuries.
Instead of fixating on this tic,
the simple solution was
just you know it's coming.
It's coming on this side,
if you stand right there,
that's where you're gonna get it.
Stand out of his reach, stand a step back.
And ignore it, ignore it!
There are other things
you could do with that,
like you could scramble
or dilute or distract.
You could gradually shape this movement
into something that was
less likely to get someone.
Like we gradually make this
movement get a little lower
so you're still doing it but
you're doing it down here
where you're not gonna get someone.
It also helped, another
recommendation we made
was let's put him in a
less crowded environment.
He did better in a home
that had fewer people
and more space so it was
easier to dodge the movement.
The main intervention, though,
was just reinterpreting
what people were seeing.
Just reinterpreting it
in neurological terms.
It didn't cure him, it didn't change him.
But that intervention was so effective
that he found a new home.
The program that he started
with this new paradigm
was focused on activities
instead of his movement problem.
And the last we heard, he was doing well.
He wasn't needing one
on one support anymore
and he was no longer at risk
of out of home placement
or placement in an institution, powerful.
An analogy to this would be
Tourette's Syndrome or stuttering.
When you have a person
with Tourette's Syndrome
who's involuntarily making loud sounds,
using swear words, or a
person who is stuttering
who's getting stuck on a word,
the best way that we can help them
is to ignore it, is to just move on.
By focusing on it, it
usually makes it worse
and it makes it more disruptive to others.
If we just ignore it and
say oops and move on,
they're able to function better.
And if we increase their anxiety
by fixating on it then it actually
makes them stutter more or makes
the involuntary movement worse.
Movement varies from more
purposeful to more automatic.
Movements that start as purposeful
can become automatic with practice.
We've all done this, it's motor memory.
You practice something
enough, you get better at it
and it becomes something that
you have to think about less.
Reflexive movements can
also become automatic
and that's probably how that started.
There was probably somebody
that this person wanted to bop
at one point but then it just became
a repetitive movement
that they couldn't stop.
Sometimes automatic
movements can be helpful.
But sometimes they aren't, for example,
it helps to practice actions like walking
and talking and do those automatically.
But if it becomes an obsession,
it can be frustrating.
For instance if I wanna put on my shoes
in the morning it's really helpful
to have the motions to put
on my shoes down really well,
to tie them and to do
that pretty automatically.
And it helps to have that
motor plan well practiced.
But if I go to the beach, I don't want
to see my shoes and have that trigger
that motor plan so I put
them on automatically
even though I'm not ready to go home.
Our ability to control our
purposeful movement is a gift.
And autistic people have other gifts,
like persistence and clear thinking.
Some movements happen unconsciously,
like the muscle movements of digestion.
There was a discussion
at the last intra-agency
autism coordinating
committee workshop on health
about whether the same
micro-movement issues
that we're finding are
affecting skeletal muscles
and our ability to control our muscles,
maybe that those same issues, I'll go back
to the slide that that, the brain is also
controlling our autonomic motor system
and the system that affects peristalsis.
That's the movements that your bowel makes
to make food go down the right
track towards the bottom.
What if the same kind of
movement discoordination
is also affecting those
automatic movements?
Maybe some of that accounts
for the constipation
that's so prevalent in autism?
So what do we know about sensory
and movement issues in autism?
By assessing the traits
and characteristics
of individuals, autism can be addressed
without even being named,
you don't need a label.
I think it's helpful to get away
from those diagnostic
labels because they free us
from our unconscious bias
about what autistic people are.
Without preconceived notions,
we can better identify
their individual
strengths and what we have
to work with and the
challenges that we have
to work around in order to provide
education, communication, and opportunity.
They're individuals, no
traits and characteristics
in common, each one different.
What learning channels are
open at any given time?
Can we get their visual attention?
Is their auditory pathway more open
to me at this moment to teach them?
What if I tried a tactile or a kinesthetic
method to focus their attention?
We have experience with this too.
Some of you are very focused
on your visual attention,
you're on your cell phone
and you're tuning me out.
But maybe there's something I could do
to get your attention
back to the auditory.
Like what if I changed
the rate of my voice
or I started to whisper or I
said something really loud?
I could get you into your auditory pathway
by doing something a little
bit different to shake it up.
What we know, what do we know about
sensory and movement issues, we know
that first performance
doesn't equal intelligence.
If an examiner asks a question,
there's all sorts of reasons why
somebody might not respond or
might not respond correctly.
Maybe there were sensory distractions.
Maybe the picture wasn't presented
in the person's narrow field of vision.
Maybe the question prompted
an automatic response
rather than a purposeful
response in response.
We see this with echolalia.
Most intelligence testing has been normed
on people who speak fluently and in people
who have very well-regulated
sensory and movement skills.
And how those norms
apply to people who don't
is something that I think
we need to question.
There's a growing body of research showing
that intelligence testing in autism
doesn't consistently
provide valid results.
And it's causing us to
underestimate people.
Think about what would happen for a second
if we administered an intelligence test
to Stephen Hawking but we took away
his AAC device so he couldn't communicate?
What if we just assumed that his inability
to respond meant that
he didn't understand?
Who else are we doing that to?
Historically we've done this
to nonspeaking people before.
We did this to the deaf community.
We presumed that people who are deaf
who had unclear speech had
intellectual disabilities.
We did it to Helen Keller,
she had to overcome
the resistance of skeptics in order
to be admitted to Radcliffe College
because people thought
her aides were giving her
the answer or communicating
for her in some way.
Intelligence, intelligence also is not
a fixed trait or a fixed capacity.
It isn't a prognosis, the full richness
of a person's cognitive and communicative
and sensory and movement function
can't be encapsulated into
a two or three digit number.
We need to presume competence,
even in people who don't speak
or whose speech is
unreliable communication.
A lot of people push back and say,
presume competence,
that's not a good thing
because clearly not all people
are geniuses underneath.
Maybe they can't communicate
but they're not all geniuses.
And that's not what
presuming competence means.
It doesn't mean that everybody
has the same cognition behind
those sensory and movement differences.
They have the full range
just like they have
the full range of other
traits and characteristics.
And it also doesn't mean
that all autistic people
have been exposed to
education or information.
But what it does mean is that we presume
that people can learn and grow
even if they can't
demonstrate what they know.
Presuming competence, it's
harder than it sounds to do.
You have to take a leap of faith
that you're making a difference
even when it isn't apparent, at least
at first, that you're succeeding.
You haven't, if you haven't seen the film,
has anybody here seen the
film Intelligent Lives?
Not too many hands going up.
It's a really great film,
it traces the history
of intellectual disability
and that concept
and it follows three people
with intellectual disabilities
as they successfully pursue education
and relationships and self-directed lives.
And increasingly, people
with autism who don't speak
and who've been labeled low-functioning
or who have been brought up in moderate
to severe Special Ed classrooms
are gaining access to higher education,
to forming families, to working,
and to pursuing a full
range of opportunities.
It's really exciting.
What are the implications?
What are the implications of these
sensory and movement differences?
Choosing therapeutic approaches needs
to be individualized
based on an assessment
that includes an understanding
of their unique and individual
sensory and movement differences.
A corollary to that is that we need
to use caution when applying evidence.
Evidence-based practice is much more
than just counting up the number
of peer-reviewed articles that show
a therapy works or it doesn't work.
We need to talk, we'll talk
more about applying evidence
in a minute and how to go about that.
Working with sensory
and movement differences
is more effective than
working against them.
That sounds obvious, right?
But it's infrequently practiced.
And in fact, the structure
of the individual
education plan system is a deficit model.
We assess people, we make a list
of every deficit they have, we come up
with a plan to for how we're
gonna address each one.
And then the dreaded
measurable objectives.
We need to be able to
prove that what we're doing
is making a difference and
in a pretty short timeframe
within three months and if we can't,
then we assume we've failed.
Presuming competence at least at first,
requires a leap of faith.
It isn't a place, in our
current educational system,
in our deficit framework for it,
there isn't a place for that.
There isn't a place for people
who haven't learned the
skills yet to demonstrate
everything they know and
to communicate fluently.
That can lead to people
getting stuck with IEPs
that are focused on weaknesses
instead of strengths
and with goals that
make them do basic work
over and over and over again.
This burns out parents
and it burns out staff too
who don't see progress despite
a lot of money and effort.
Everybody needs a fluent form
of expressive communication.
This needs to be an early and
top priority, don't give up.
The Office of Developmental
Primary Care's guide,
Everybody Communicates, is
available out there at our table.
It's also available
online and it helps you
figure out how to get an assessment
that takes into account sensory, movement,
and cognitive differences
and how to assess services.
There's also information in your handout,
the United for Communication Choices
website has information.
When exploring options for treatment,
listen to autistic people,
read what they say.
I've given you a small sampling
of blogs in your handout, go explore them.
Find people who have similar traits
and characteristics to the individual
you're trying to help and
see what worked for them.
And see, those are probably gonna
be the most fruitful approaches.
Because of unconscious bias,
people are routinely underestimated.
So presume competence, be skeptical
about IQ tests, don't
let a number determine
your opportunities or your potential.
So I promised you we would come back
to applying evidence and I wanna talk
about this 'cause it's important
because I think a lot of the
professional organizations
are moving towards what they
call evidence-based practice,
and wow that sounds fabulous doesn't it?
And I, as a physician,
was a medical editor.
And I started in the
American Family Physician,
the Cochran for Clinicians Department
which is all about
evidence-based practice.
I'm a strong supporter of
it, but I also recognize
that only 10% of what
we do in medicine even,
is based on good quality
randomized control trials
or other high-quality evidence.
Clinical trials can only
answer very narrow questions.
I think it was Einstein who said,
not everything that can
be studied is important
and not everything
important can be studied.
When we're talking about people
with such unique and a wide range
of traits and characteristics,
it's hard to generalize
from the experience
of one person or one group
of people to another.
They can be very different.
People have also found
highly idiosyncratic
and highly effective
ways of communicating,
of learning, and of navigating the world.
If something is proven
useful for an individual,
that's evidence-based for that individual.
We don't have to look at that individual
and say this thing that
you're finding so successful
and that's improving your life
and that we can see you participating
in your home, in your
school, in your community,
and accessing the general
curriculum must be fake
because we don't have
a peer-reviewed article
to prove that it's legitimate.
No, it's legitimate for that person.
For that person you can see
it's completely empiric.
For an individual, the presence or absence
of peer-reviewed literature is irrelevant
if something is working for them.
The peer-reviewed
literature is very relevant
if you are a professional and trying
to say okay, out of this
range of treatments,
what is, what has the
best percentage chance
of being effective in this person?
Then it's important
but when you're talking
about an individual who's
already using a technique,
even an idiosyncratic
technique effectively,
there's no reason to interrupt it.
So when we're assessing whether
to apply research to
a specific individual,
here's what evidence-based
practice tells us to do.
First, does this individual share the same
traits and characteristics and conditions
as the people in the study?
So if we have an FMRI
study and it was done
on people who can cooperate
with getting into an MRI,
does it apply to an autistic person
who that would be unimaginable?
They wouldn't be able to sit there.
It probably doesn't.
Saying that this was a study
of autism isn't enough.
We need to know whether the actual traits
and characteristics of
the people in the study
are similar to the person
we're trying to help.
And sometimes the research just stops
with well they have a diagnosis
of autism and it was done with
these standardized methods
and they don't really give
you a lot of information
about the unique traits
and characteristics
of the people they
enrolled in their study.
It may be very hard to
know whether you can
generalize that study to
your particular individual.
Second, are the outcome measures
meaningful to your client?
For example, a communication method
that only allows you to request food items
at snack at school is not very meaningful
especially if your goal
is to get an education
and to communicate your
authentic thoughts.
Not all outcomes are equally meaningful
to the person you're trying to help.
Is the outcome that this intervention
is purporting to help
something that my patient
cares about, my individual
patient cares about?
Are the methods valid?
Some research methods are
more rigorous than others,
but to be valid you have to determine
if the test measures what
it's supposed to measure.
For example, if you're trying to study
the outcomes of an intervention
on the ability of someone to communicate
in their day-to-day life
in a natural setting
with receptive and supportive
communication partners,
does a study that was done in an exam room
with someone who was
trying to read a script
and be very neutral and objective,
does it measure that?
What if the test of communication
consisted of a bunch of vocabulary drills?
Does that really measure your ability
to communicate your authentic
thoughts, is it relevant?
Maybe it's research, they reported
their observations but it may not be valid
in the sense that it's not measuring
what you're hoping to measure.
It's not valid in that construct way.
Is the, another consideration,
is the therapy available and
is there a way to implement it?
And if there isn't then
as regional center staff
and vendors we need to fix that problem.
But in the meantime, in the meantime
that's not helpful to your patient,
at least not immediately.
So unfortunately often the answer is
that the therapies that are working best
aren't available in public schools.
And some of that is the structure
of the IEP system and some of
it is logistical challenges
with implementing some of the most
effective methods in
public school settings.
A lot of them are one to one, they're hard
to implement in group settings.
They require expertise
that's hard to develop
when people, when staff
turnover is very great.
So there are significant challenges
to making therapies available to people
and that needs to be taken into account
when we decide what we offer
to people and what we recommend.
In addition to studying
whether a method works,
we need to study what else it does.
What are the risks,
what are the downsides?
Just because it helps in one way
doesn't mean that the
risk benefit balance is,
is favorable on the whole.
And finally is the treatment consistent
with the patient's cultural values,
with the disability community's
values and their expectations?
These are all things to
take into consideration
and I wanna tell you another story
from our consult practice to illustrate
why it's so important to be careful
about how we apply evidence.
We were consulted on a
non-speaking autistic girl
who was having very serious
self-injurious behavior
and her school was at their wit's end
and said they could no longer serve her.
So we reviewed her records
and we noted she's blind and deaf.
Because her school was dedicated
to evidence-based practice for autism,
they were implementing PECS,
those are picture icons,
to support her communication.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, that's the mainstay of most autism
special education programs
and she's autistic,
so yeah, we'll do PECS.
She couldn't see them,
her parents asked us,
why aren't they teaching her a form
of tactile sign language,
she's frustrated and bored?
And we asked the same question,
and we got them in contact with people
who use these other methods.
And there were very sincere people
working really hard,
putting a lot of resources
into helping this person
with evidence-based methods
but the assessment of what the,
the assessment of her unique traits
and characteristics wasn't there.
And it ended up frustrating her,
leading to behavioral issues
and frustrating the staff
who were working so, so hard at something
that just wasn't getting them anywhere.
They kept, it's frustrating
if you've ever been judged
based on whether someone's making progress
in those measurable
objectives and they aren't.
And they're not going to if
you're using the wrong method
because you have the wrong diagnosis.
You have the wrong understanding
of what the issues are.
I don't want you to just listen to me.
I want you to listen to what
self-advocates are saying.
We need to listen to
what they're telling us
about what works for them
so let's hear directly
from a self-advocate
about their experience
living with these sensory
and movement differences.
This video is, this video shows
what it's like to be trapped
inside an unruly body.
The video's about seven minutes
and it might be emotional for some people
so feel free to take a
break if you need to.
- My son Payam was asked
to give a presentation
at Georgia Tech in February of 2018
at the Innovations in
Education Conference.
He titled his speech
Rethinking Autism and
Therapeutic Approaches.
Payam decided to open and close live
in front of the audience
in order to show them
the effort and time it takes to spell out
each word letter by
letter on the keyboard.
There once was a time in my life
where I struggled to feel included
in the world that surrounded me.
Tears would sometime pour
like rain on a river.
The thought of never expressing
my wonderful, deep inner
thoughts scared me tremendously.
Would my parents see the real me?
Will they truly hear my passion
to learn from others who, like me,
have dealt with adversity?
These are the questions I ask
myself from a very young age.
Trying to make sense of the world
became a game I played daily
in order to occupy myself.
Hearing words and conversations
filled my wandering mind
with meaningful thoughts.
The challenge was that outsiders
could not see or measure the
intelligence I was acquiring.
For years, I underwent various types
of treatments and therapies.
This was frustrating at times,
but without a real way
to express my opinions,
I faced treatments with bravery.
Figuring out that I may be trapped
in silence forever occurred
to me around the age of nine.
This realization was both
startling and freeing for me.
The truth is, I never gave up on the idea
that there would be a time for others
to find out I was trapped
inside an unruly body
with a lousy mouth that disobeyed.
I still have moments when I'm tired
of having to deal with the nonsense
my body gets wrapped up in.
Tireless days are spent
growing against impulses
that exhaust me and my
loved ones, yet I persevere.
Safe days with loving teachers
help remind me of all
I want to accomplish.
Eventually, we found a way I could share
my great mind with the world around me.
Working meticulously hard, I learned how
to harness my kind but careless body
to spell out fearless thoughts.
Each day I look forward
now, lucky to be surrounded
by family and friends
who not only see through
my outward facade but also the
other silent champions too.
Challenging perceptions
will be my life's work.
Creating shifts takes time.
Respectful dialogues lessen
resistance to change.
This must be carefully cultivated
with professionals, educators,
caregivers, and of course,
the individual who is in need.
The time has come for professionals
and educators to take
advice from advocates
with personal experiences
with chaotic impulses.
Try to imagine what life would be like
living without direct control over
words, limbs, and motor actions.
This way of living is all I know.
Speech would be helpful
or so one might think.
Not always the case.
Imagine saying every inner
thought uncontrollably,
or getting trapped in a repetitive
pattern of nonsense chatter.
But nothing is worse than being perceived
as less capable than you truly are.
My friends and I have dealt with this lack
of honest understanding most of our lives.
Try to see past this and ask yourself,
what more could be missing?
What strategies could be used to support
an individual in school,
home or the community?
This evolution will take time to unfold.
Progressive thinkers
will need to carefully
help traditional professionals
find new strategies.
Respectful advocates will open minds
with their wise insights and perspectives.
Let us work together to create
dynamic shifts for future generations.
This is my opportunity to give input,
but there are many more
who need to be heard too.
The most important piece
to any child's success
is to feel included, this is difficult
for educators to problem
solve without the right tools.
Identifying the right
tool should be a priority.
For me, it was learning to communicate
by spelling each word on stencil boards.
Each individual may require
their own unique supports.
Do not deny anyone this right,
regardless of what your opinion may be.
There are times when individuals
with tough bodies will
challenge your patience.
Try to care for us the way you hope
to be cared for in your time of need.
Treat us with kindness, pay
attention to our patterns,
and help us to learn strategies
to redirect our body.
Never underestimate what we can learn.
Fortunately there are plenty of advocates
who can back this up with examples.
It is not just what our brains
are capable of, but our bodies too.
Figuring out how to support a
rhetorically challenged body
requires deep introspection
from all parties.
My teachers are not confused
by my seemingly random habits.
Instead they organize my actions
with meaningful activities,
training my brain
to focus on exercises, games, and tasks,
that will utilize both my brain and body.
Communicating has been the best support
in giving me something
to focus my energy on.
The more we talk about this
as a community the better.
Every single person interacting
with those with brain-body disconnect
can have an impact on our lives.
There must be fundamental changes
in our belief in all of humanity.
Treating individual people as though
they not only matter but can make
a difference in this world is essential.
Help make this happen.
Opportunities for those like
me are harder to come by.
You all have the power to influence
your families, peers, and
professional communities.
Can you rise up?
- Payam isn't alone.
I have another non-speaking self-advocate
responded to the
question, what do you want
professionals to know about
communication with these words.
What I want people to
know about communication
is that it has nothing
to do with intelligence.
It's a motor planning issue.
Before basic scientists
researched brain anatomy,
psychiatrists assumed that
autistic behavior is purposeful.
This has caused problems
for autistic people
all over the world, it isn't helpful
to do drills or positive behavior plans
because they don't work
on the brain disfunction
that makes speech hard.
Another reason they don't work
is because they cause
anxiety and low self-esteem.
Many people believe they're helping
because they make charts and graphs
and errorless learning models.
It's as if they don't know that
people learn from mistakes.
Behavioral training is
merely drilling motor plans,
so with a prompt you get
the response you want.
But it isn't neccesarily
the response intended.
The intent may be help, stop,
you're underestimating me.
I want to learn regular lessons.
Talk to me normally, stop patronizing me.
It's making me fear for my future.
Let me understand my body
and harness it so we can be friends.
The basic science of autism
and the sensory movement differences
and the study of dyspraxia and autism
is expanding rapidly but it still
doesn't constitute a coherent story.
Research can only answer
very narrow questions.
Even without a full understanding though,
it's pretty clear to me that this line
of basic science research
is on the right track
and it correlates much
better with what we observe.
I hope that you will explore the resources
that are in your packet and on this slide.
And next year, if you are interested,
we may be able to convince
the conference chairs
to invite educators and parents
and self-advocates who are finding ways
to harness their unruly bodies
to meet with you and
talk to you in person.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)